alors je vais vous dire pourquoi y'a
louis morin 1 parce que j'aime beaucoup
c'est un journaliste voilà tout à fait
journaliste politique amène à notre
chien là tu vas aller donc on a dix
politiques et médias je voulais au
départ
matthieu delormeau on n'a pas réussi à
joindre jusqu'à 16 heures il était prévu
dans l'émission on n'a pas réussi à
joindre
donc forcément on avait prévu quelqu'un
d'autre et je voulais pas des bouquets
louis donc oui vous êtes là vous prenez
bien ordonnée le cachet de matthieu
delormeau pas pour le mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes accord exact
journalistes médias et notamment comment
vous étiez vous étiez à la radio si
c'était la radio est tout à fait c'était
sur une radio qui s'appelle sud radio
pendant six ans bah oui mais la radio il
existe toujours
y a que vous qui n'est plus comme il est
pas beau il est exceptionnellement beau
il est très demandé
ben oui vous êtes un petit peu les 100
mètres de cette émission où s'opposeront
genre elles et leurs calots bleus non il
a eu là quelque chose les filles
ludivine est magnifique
il est super intelligent j'adore le
moral chiffres mais aussi vous voulez
comme tout le monde j'aime la beauté
j'aime la beauté désole jean mi
c'est votre chine se faire max pas mon
style je plaisante avec un max à temps
on se rend compte qu'ils se pinçant d'or
wave asie la papaye marcel tous les jeux
meilleurs tout couac et mina niasse élus
gnagna tous les jours s'il voudra comme
ça quel ignare suis pas sûr que ça
marche pas très bien derrière ces noms
on peut retrouver les archives en
septembre dans cette émission même tu
avais dit linverse d'accord calme toi
quand même